SA, THANK Y
G THESE QU
THANK YOU. > SPERATE PLEA FM
ARKANSAS FAMILY WITH A CUENH
TH PERYBODE VACCINE.R-SPLAYED CP
PARENTS GOT HIM CHECKED OUT AND
HE HAS COVIDBE HOSPIZEAND
WAT ON
R AND IGSISTER A.
WITH US.EI
KYLE, IT'SHE HARDEST THING IN
K ANT IMAGINE
TO HAVE D  ABLE TOT HIM IS YOURR
ITEAY HELPS DELIVER THE AGATYTH
TRYING TO T SSAGE OUT.
AS FAR AS WHAT IT'S LIKE, WE BE.
THAT.OSPITAL FOR RT EVEN G AN ID
THEY'RE JUST TINCT EIR EMPLOYEET
BUT IT'SRIBLE.T OPLE TO
LPW, I.R WIFE I
ANOW COU TEELSITL.
NOT THAT IT MAKES IT ANY
ON.
A SENSE OF HO
CARTDOING. REALLY TOH AN
GOPAST 24 HOURS HAVEN
ER.
HE'S STILL ON OXYGEN.
AND S DOCTORE STILL
NG THE BUILDUPNGS, GETT OUT
WITH TREATMENTS.
THOR HIM NOW IS S  FEVEROWN
FOE
. SO DIFFICULT FOR URTING HITHT
ANYOEA CLY SOMEONE
GRAVITUAON AND A
HIHOUR SODNG.LEEPS , WE BOTHER
, LTY TO TT  T
HELP. E E PICTURES
THAT  AND S
HE
CADE T ATL
UN- THAT'S A PICTURE
E SLEEPS LIKE A WR
MOST OF THTIS HAPPY, N'T RY MUC.
HES  PY.IKES GOING O
HE VC. HIM
ET HIM HTH YOU
SO THAT YOU  CINISTH
SICK?ANT THING.EO NEED TO DO M
OU KNOW, I'VE HEARD FROM
CAN DOO HELP, ANMYSAGE TORYKIEY
TO THA ROUGH THIS OR TO PREVENT
AT AWE GESTURE IS
A VERYICE  THE
GRAVITY OF SITUATION IS
HELP ME.NOTHING YOU CAN DO TO
I CAN'T GO TSPITAL
I CAN'T EVEN HEL
THERE'S NOTHINYOO
HELP T
THERE'NO THINGOU CO TO
PREVENT  FM DOING  YOUVALDE
>> KYLE -- ANOTHER FAMILYOE HAVW
>> S BBULANCE AND NDE YOU'OI S
BECAUSE YO CAN HELP ME.
HAO BET ABOUT IT,
BUTHU CA P  DP THRE
ARE LISTENIN
YOU.
I THINK UCSSAGE.
'S1-TOR. WE'RE
AND 'RT  CAN.
UT VACCINATE
HELP ATH THEIRS WHERE THEY
>> THANK YOU.N.
WE APPRECIATE IT THERE A
PEOPLE WATCHINAT WHO ARE
HAVING AS HARDM  KEEPING ITOGETR
OWFAY KEIT'S HARD NOT TOUMN  HFA
>> I THINK, LOOK, WE TALKED ITH
ABOUT .IN GENS AT RISK.
THA LOT
WHOREE HOSPITAL GHNO LIK
ABS OR
THEY'RR THEY'R
AND THG THEMD.N UNACCEPTABBER.T